CATHY CHEN: Hi, everyone.
I'm Cathy Chen, and I am
a product manager here
in Cambridge.
I just wanted to kind
of express how excited I
am to bring Debbie here to
Cambridge to talk to all of us.
I'm actually a grad student at
Columbia University full time
in a masters degree
program in something called
organizational psychology.
And one of the things
that we cover there
is leadership and a lot of
things around gender, also
negotiations.
So I've had the privilege
of having Debbie
as a lecturer for my course.
And so my class actually
ranges from people
who are politicians,
like there's
a mayor of a small
town in Connecticut,
all the way through like a
chief of staff to a senator.
And then there's other people
who are like chief of IT
for a hospital,
that kind of thing.
And even then in that class,
like of very experienced
people, everybody learned
something about negotiations
when Debbie was there.
So another day during
class, Debbie actually
talked a little bit more
about diversity and leadership
training.
And so I'm really
pleased to have her here
to talk a little bit about both.
Debbie is a Deloitte
Ellen Gabriel Professor
for Women in Leadership
Emerita-- she doesn't look
retired, but she is-- and a
distinguished research fellow
at the Center for
Gender in Organizations
at Simmons School of Management.
And for those of you who
don't know much about Simmons,
the center is actually funded
by the Ford Foundation.
From 1991 to '94, Debbie
was executive director
of the Program on Negotiations
at Harvard Law School.
And she currently
is a senior fellow
of that program, where she
co-directs the negotiations
at the Workplace Project.
She's also an adjunct professor
at INSEAD business school
in Fontainebleau, France.
Debbie runs women's
executive leadership programs
for places like Time Warner
and Deloitte and Deutsche Bank.
And using what she's
observed about executives
there in these
leadership programs,
Debbie has integrated those
stories into this book.
So the book is based on
women's real-life examples.
She's also written
many books and articles
about conflict and mediation and
is an authority on negotiation.
So today, she's here to
talk about her fourth book
on negotiations and gender.
And if you want
more any information
about those other books
that she's written,
you can find her bio
and the website link
on Go Negotiating at Work.
There's also a Dory there
if you have questions,
and she's going to talk
for about half an hour
and then take
questions at the end.
So with no further ado,
here's Debbie Kolb.
[APPLAUSE]
DEBORAH KOLB: Thank you, Cathy.
Can you hear me?
God, this is hard.
The light is right in my eyes.
I'm delighted,
actually, to be here.
In preparation, I read
the book about Google
by your former CEO and
Jonathan Rosenberg.
And I can tell you, negotiation
is an important part of work
there, it seemed to me.
So let me just place
this book in context
before I sort of talk about
some of the principles
of negotiation that
are in the book.
So I've written a lot of
books about negotiation.
The one that was most well
known was something called
"The Shadow Negotiation."
And in that book, what I
did was I looked at-- we
know about getting to yes,
about principles of mutual gains
negotiation.
In "The Shadow
Negotiation," I talked
about building relationships and
how you advocate for yourself
and connect with others.
And so that book
has done quite well.
It came out in paperback
with a different title.
But through my leadership
development activities,
both leadership programs
for women, but also more
generally-- so Cathy's
program is obviously
a mixed group-- I
really started to see
how experienced
leaders manage some
of the challenges of
internal negotiation.
And the actual
motivation for this book
came from-- I run a program
in Chicago that brings people
from different companies
for several module
program on the academic
advisor, and I teach in it.
And at the end of one
of these programs when
you're saying
goodbye to everybody,
and everybody is
hugging and kissing,
this woman came up
to me and she said,
the negotiation
module change my life.
I'm thinking, wow, that's
really pretty terrific.
There must be a story here.
And so she told me her story,
and from her setting this idea
in motion about stories, I
started to collect stories
from experienced practitioners.
So this is a book about stories
I've done a lot of
work on this topic
before when I've interviewed.
But this is a different
book, because it's
got these stories in
it from practitioners.
So let me ask you a question.
How many of you would
describe yourselves--
so this is a question
that I always
ask at the beginning
of a leadership program
that I teach in negotiation.
I ask the question, how
many have you would describe
yourself as successful
in dealing with clients,
customers, suppliers,
places where
you are acting as an agent,
either for your group
or for Google?
How many of you would describe
yourself as successful in that?
OK.
And then I can ask-- I have
no way of verifying this--
what makes you successful?
So what makes you successful?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: The ability to
accomplish your original goal.
DEBORAH KOLB: Yeah,
so being positioned
to accomplish your goals.
And what makes you get into a
position to accomplish that?
AUDIENCE: Largely relationship.
DEBORAH KOLB: OK, so you build
relationships with people
externally.
What else makes you successful?
What else makes you successful
when you act as an agent?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I'm really nice.
DEBORAH KOLB: You're nice.
[LAUGHS] What does that mean,
nice?
You're collaborative?
You're willing to
make concessions?
What does nice mean?
AUDIENCE: I'm willing
to talk to people.
I like to listen to them.
DEBORAH KOLB: OK, so
you're a good listener.
Right, you're trying to
find some kind of agreement
that both of you are happy with.
So that means nice.
What else makes you successful?
?
Yeah
AUDIENCE: Knowing who to go to
[INAUDIBLE] person situation.
DEBORAH KOLB: Right, so
knowing the right people.
People always say, I'm
very well prepared.
I know the right people.
I know what they're
likely to do.
I'm very well prepared
under those circumstances.
I listen.
I look for mutual
gains, agreements.
I assume that's
what's behind nice.
And so then I ask
the question-- that's
negotiating as an agent, what
I call this capital letter N
Negotiation.
And then I ask the
question, what's
different when you're
negotiating for yourself?
You're not an agent.
You're what we call a principle.
So what's different when
you negotiate for yourself?
What's different?
Nothing?
It's the same?
AUDIENCE: It's not usually
as mutually beneficial.
DEBORAH KOLB: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: It's not usually
as mutually beneficial.
DEBORAH KOLB: It's not so
clear how you can discover
what's mutually beneficial.
It might depend
on the situation.
What else is different?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I think
people react differently
when they see someone asking for
something on behalf of others
versus for themselves.
DEBORAH KOLB: Right,
because what do they see?
So what do they see and
then what do you feel?
AUDIENCE: Even if
you don't feel it,
it's easy to feel
like, oh, I shouldn't
be asking [INAUDIBLE].
Even if you don't, people
just see it differently.
DEBORAH KOLB: And so
they see it differently
and you sort of incorporate
that a little bit.
You can feel a little
bit greedy asking, right?
And so it might make negotiation
a little bit more emotional.
What else?
AUDIENCE: All the
emotions can run
higher if you feel
like a personal attack,
if you feel like an imposition.
DEBORAH KOLB: We're
bothering people.
It's just sort of much
harder in negotiating
with this what I call this sort
of lowercase n negotiations.
It's hard to get
negotiations started.
We don't have a
structure for doing it.
It's often hard to figure out
what you want in this context.
When you're capital
letter N Negotiating,
it's pretty clear about
what you're going after.
You might change your ideas.
But when you're
negotiating for yourself,
sometimes it's hard to do that.
It might be hard to
stay in the negotiation.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
When you say lowercase
n negotiation,
are you referring to both
parties being individuals,
or are you referring
to where one of them
is an individual or principle
and the other one is actually
an organization?
DEBORAH KOLB: I'm
actually thinking
about-- you could be
negotiating-- what's
an example of you as a little
n negotiation negotiating
with an organization?
AUDIENCE: Well,
one, for example,
say you're negotiating
a salary increase.
It's an example of
where you're not really
negotiating with your
superior as an individual.
You're negotiating with
them as a representative
of the larger--
DEBORAH KOLB: But
it manifests itself
as an individual
negotiation, right?
The position they take
is they are representing
the total organization,
and when they
respond to what
you ask for, that's
what they're representing.
But it actually is two
individuals actually sitting
down and negotiating.
Is that right?
AUDIENCE: But how would
that be any different
from an uppercase N
Negotiation, where it's still
two individuals negotiating.
DEBORAH KOLB: Well, that's
what I'm asking you.
Is it different?
AUDIENCE: Well,
I would think so.
Because--
DEBORAH KOLB: Because in the
first situation, in capital N
Negotiation, you are
representative negotiating
with a representative.
In lowercase n
negotiation, you're
negotiating on behalf of
yourself as an individual.
And you might
negotiate with somebody
who's representing something
else, but you're the agent.
And so, is it different?
AUDIENCE: Right.
I guess what I'm trying to ask
is that are you distinguishing
the two cases where
you as an individual
and negotiating with an
organization versus you
as an individual--
DEBORAH KOLB: I'm distinguishing
when you are negotiating
on behalf of yourself.
I don't care who you're
negotiating with.
AUDIENCE: All right, got it.
DEBORAH KOLB: It
could actually be
buying a car, could be
a little n negotiation.
You're negotiating
with a car dealership,
but you want the best
price, and it's you,
unless you're
negotiating on behalf
of your parents, your children,
your spouse, or somebody.
You're negotiating
as a principle.
So the thing that's
important to me
is who you are in
those negotiations.
We'll also talk about who
the other person is as well.
So let me ask you some
questions about what
kinds of little n negotiations
do you have at Google?
What do you negotiate about
when you're negotiating
for yourself at Google?
What kinds do you have?
AUDIENCE: Who gets
assigned a bug.
DEBORAH KOLB: Who gets assigned
a bug. [LAUGHS] So work, right?
What else?
And you have a preference
about that or not, right?
AUDIENCE: Not me.
[LAUGHING]
DEBORAH KOLB: What?
What did you say?
AUDIENCE: Not me.
DEBORAH KOLB: You don't
want to get it, right?
OK, what else do you negotiate
about, little n negotiations
at Google?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Career development
or growth opportunities.
DEBORAH KOLB: Yeah,
career development,
growth opportunities.
Those are negotiations.
You're trying to get
things that you can do.
That's a little a negotiation.
You're negotiating on
behalf of yourself.
What else do you negotiate for?
AUDIENCE: A desk where you sit.
DEBORAH KOLB: A desk to sit, OK.
I didn't really
think about that,
but I guess that that would
be true, a desk, where to sit.
What else?
AUDIENCE: Also flexible
work arrangements.
DEBORAH KOLB: Flexible
work arrangements
can be that as well.
So I think as we
go through this,
it would be useful for you to
have in your mind a little n
negotiation that you
might be struggling with.
So that as we talk
about it, you might
be able to think about it.
So what I want to
do is add gender
to our story of
little n negotiations.
And I want to say a few things.
So we have a class here.
Gender is not just about women.
And when I talk
about gender, I'm
not talking about
the differences
between men and women.
I'm talking about what we
call second-generation gender
issues, that is, policies and
practices and culture that
on its face looks
natural and neutral
but can have differential
impacts on men and women
and different groups
of men and women.
And I always like to say
when we talk about women
and these issues, I
always like to say
it's like the
canary in the mine,
that we sort of understand
some of the issues that
might be affecting a minority
group, which is true at Google,
might have implications for
the majority group as well.
So one of the ways we like
to talk about what it means
to talk about second-generation
gender issues,
is to use the example
of the US Capitol.
So the US Capitol was
built in the 1800s.
100 And of course
when they built it,
they had no ladies
rooms, because they
had no ladies, right?
And in 1917, the first
woman was elected
to the US House
of Representatives
and in 1932, the
first to the Senate.
Prior to 1962, congresswomen
shared a single bathroom
far from the chamber,
even though there
were many in the House.
In 1992, the women
senators were given
restrooms on the same floor
as the Senate chamber.
In 2011, four stall bathrooms
were put in the House.
And in 2013, they actually
put women's restrooms
in the Senate near
the chamber when
there were 20 women senators.
And so the idea is that nobody
was doing this explicitly
to discriminate.
It just was there were no
women, and so there wasn't
need for a women's restrooms.
And that's sort of the idea
about second-generation gender
issues.
That is, they come
into existence
because they fit the
lives and the work styles
of a certain majority group.
And we don't think about
how it works for people
that aren't in that majority.
So let me give you some
examples about where
negotiation comes in there.
The first is people
are offered jobs
that they don't want to take,
like fix the bug, right?
And you're expected to say yes.
And so what are some of those?
Well, in financial
service organizations,
it is often the
case that women get
assigned managerial operational
jobs, that is, run the office,
run a country.
And there's not a
lot of value to that.
Obviously the value is in
sales in financial services.
Or in a major manufacturing
company I know of,
women get channeled into
human resource roles,
because the idea, the belief is
if they're in operations, which
is really the
privileged place, they
won't be able to manage it
because of work and family
issues.
Or in professional
services firms,
women often get put in
chief of staff roles, right?
And the key thing there is
you're asked to do something,
you might not want
to do it, and so
the key is how you
negotiate to make it
fit with what you want to do.
The second is we have
outdated job criteria.
So often people
aren't on the screen.
So somebody mentioned
negotiating for opportunities,
and that's one of
the things there.
So in one organization,
people say, hire like me.
At a certain level
in an organization,
people don't know
exactly what they're
looking for in leadership.
So the best thing is,
let me find someone
who looks just like me, right?
And so if you don't fit that, if
you don't look just like that,
it's up to you to negotiate
for that opportunity.
I do a lot of work in Africa.
And there is a story
about this woman
who lived in rural Nairobi.
She's a PhD scientist.
And all the important
work was in Nairobi.
But nobody ever offered
her an opportunity
because they assumed
she wouldn't move,
that she wouldn't leave her
family that was in rural Kenya.
Or another woman
who picked up work
when her boss left
and was actually doing
the work of a vice
president, and she did it
for three months,
but nobody thought
to offer her the actual role.
So she had to negotiate it.
Women often get asked to
do more invisible work.
There was just a column
in the "New York Times"
by Sheryl Sandberg and Adam
Grant about housework at work,
being asked to do things
like mentor other people.
I think this happens
for people who are
different as well, diversity.
Mentor other
people, run a group,
be on the diversity committee,
all those kinds of things
that are extra work and they are
presumed that you will do it.
It's invisible work.
And so part of the challenge
there is negotiate value.
And one of the
things that we know
is that when people
do invisible work,
it actually has a benefit
for organizations.
And so we have to
claim value for that.
Integrating work
and family, right?
So somebody said flexible
work arrangements.
Well, it isn't just
flexible work arrangements.
We have this vision
of the ideal worker,
and boy, the ideal worker
at Google is alive and well.
I think you're supposed to
be there all the time, right?
The heroic stories
in this book were
about people who worked long
weekends and long nights
to do all the work.
So if you have family
responsibilities,
that becomes sort of an issue.
And the way is, how do you
negotiate to make that work?
One of my favorite stories
is about this woman
who was in procurement
in and oil and gas.
And to get promoted, you had
to relocate, in this situation,
to Ghana.
And she had a family.
She didn't want to live
in Ghana for three years.
But what she was
able to negotiate
was sort of a
commuting relationship
so that she was in Ghana
for a few weeks at a time
and then would
come back to Dallas
and go back, so negotiating
to make work arrangements work
in the face of expectations
about the ideal worker.
And the final thing is
about mandate for change.
So there's this research
that's about the glass cliff.
And here's the story.
The story is that when
organizations are not
doing well, the
likelihood that a woman is
going to be put in a senior
leadership role goes up, right?
Think Marissa Mayer.
Think Mary Barra
at General Motors.
Think Meg Whitman
at Hewlett Packard.
And so the glass cliff
means that you're
put in charge of these
risky enterprises.
And I guess the
reason it's called
a glass cliff is if you
succeed, great, if not,
you're off the cliff.
But the idea is when you take
on one of these risky roles,
you need to
negotiate for support
so if it doesn't do all that
well, you're sort of protected.
So what I want to do is
talk about three challenges.
I've spent a lot of time
talking about the context.
So I want to talk about three
things-- getting negotiations
off the ground, because
the structure doesn't look
the same in little
n negotiations; get
their situation, that is, really
trying to understand where
they're coming from; and
dealing with their resistance
to change.
So here's the challenge.
"Excuse me, I'm here
to talk about resources
for my project." "Yeah, later."
So little n negotiations
don't have a structure, right?
You have to construct
them out of whole cloth.
So what are some of the
ways you get negotiations
off the ground?
There are two major ways that
we write about in the book.
There are others as well.
The first one is to
make your value visible.
People negotiate
with you because you
have something they want.
And you need to make it visible
in what we call a currency that
matters to them.
So it isn't just
that you work hard.
It's what they think about
that matters to them that
makes a difference.
Because you're trying to build
in some kind of reciprocity.
That is, you're trying
to get them to the table.
So let me tell you a story.
This is about a woman.
She was a director of external
relations at a very large
Midwest manufacturing company.
And she was asked by people in
another division-- they were
the legislative
division-- to help
save a really important client
that they had at the state
level.
They were about to
lose the client,
and it was going to be a very
big-- this is a company that
supplies resources, all
kinds of equipment and stuff
to companies and businesses and
buildings, stuff for buildings.
And so she did it.
She helped.
She saved this client.
She got a huge amount
of kudos, presented
to the board, the CEO.
It was terrific.
But then they kept asking
her to keep doing it.
They would call her
up, and they would say,
we need your help
again in another state.
And she really liked to
help, so she would help.
But she found that
she was spending
a lot of time doing this
work, and it was not her job.
So the first thing that she
did is she goes to her boss,
and she tries to make her value
visible in a currency that
matters to him.
So she costs her contribution,
how much time she's spending
and what it costs.
And then she talks
about what how
she's really saved the client,
what a benefit it has been.
So she makes her value
visible in what she thinks
is a currency that has value.
And he says, it's terrific,
but the time isn't right.
You need to be patient.
So that's making
her value visible.
It didn't actually work.
So the second is
using your leverage.
And what do we mean
by your leverage?
Well, there is a
concept in negotiation.
Probably many of you know it.
I mean, I think a lot of you
have taken negotiation courses
here at Google.
The concept of BATNA--
everybody know BATNA?
Your Best Alternative To
a Negotiated Agreement--
you ask yourself, what happens
if I can't reach agreement
here?
What am I can be forced to do?
What are they going
to be forced to do?
So in her situation,
her BATNA is what?
What's her alternative
if she can't
get her boss to negotiate?
What's her BATNA?
It's actually to stop doing
the work for this other group.
But she does it in a way that
we call smoothing out your BATNA
so it isn't so abrupt or
so threatening, maybe.
So the first thing that she
does is she uses questions.
She goes to this other group
the next time they ask her,
and she says, this is really
taking too much of my time.
I'm really concerned.
How will you handle this
if I don't do it, right?
So she's letting them know
about her alternative,
but she's doing it in a
way that's very engaging.
And so they say, well,
there is somebody that's
supposed to be handling
it, but that person
doesn't do a very good job.
So I don't think it
would really work for us.
We really do need you.
Then she says to them,
let's focus on the purpose.
I always like to say,
you want to connect
what's good for you to what's
good for the organization.
And so she talked
to them about why
it would be good for her to have
this work as part of her job.
And they say,
right, it would be.
And so they become her ally.
And they go to her
boss and they say,
we really need-- this
woman's name was Isabel--
we need Isabel to do this.
And that gets her
boss to the table.
So she gets him to the table.
They reorganize her job.
She now has the legislative
part as part of her work.
And the key thing was is
that she used her alternative
with somebody else who could
act as an ally for her.
So I'm interested-- do you
have problems getting people
to the table?
And what kinds of
things have you used?
What are some of
the things you've
used to get people to the
table to negotiate with you?
AUDIENCE: So in a
salary negotiation,
I used an offer from
another company.
DEBORAH KOLB: Right.
So there's a really
interesting way to do that.
In the book we call it
smoothing out your BATNA.
So one of the things
you can say is,
I have this other offer, right?
That's just letting
them know your BATNA.
Smoothing out your
your BATNA is saying,
I have this other offer,
but I'd much rather
stay at Google, right?
So you let them know
about you BATNA,
you do it in a very
engaging kind of way.
And I think this idea about
smoothing out your BATNA
is a really nice concept.
It lets people know
you have alternatives,
but you do it in
a way that I think
is consistent with a
collaborative culture
at Google.
Any other things that people
have used to get people
to the table with them?
Nothing else?
No other hints?
OK, well hopefully
you'll use some of these.
No?
OK.
So let me go to the next
point that I want to make,
which is the idea about
getting who they are
and what they want.
So we had this sense
that in negotiation, we
want to focus on people's
interest to come up
with mutual gains agreements.
But there's more
behind what people
want than just the issues
that are on the table.
The person you're
negotiating with
considers him or herself in
the context of the larger
organization.
So for example, if you're
negotiating salary,
if somebody is going to give
you a salary that you want,
they want to think about,
what's the implication of this
to other people, right?
So this notion of how they
think about themselves in
relation to the things
that they might give you.
And so I usually like
to put this slide up,
because one the things
we think about is we
tend to see ourselves
as the heroes
and heroines of our stories.
So we like to say
we're strategic,
we take the long-term
perspective,
we see the big picture, we
act in the organization's best
interest, we're flexible
and collaborative.
They, on the other
hand, are opportunistic.
They're short-term thinkers.
They have narrow vision.
They're out for themselves,
rigid and uncooperative.
And I have to tell you, nobody
wakes up in the morning,
looks at him or herself
in the mirror, and says,
I'm opportunistic, I'm
a short-term thinker,
I have narrow vision, I'm
out for myself and are rigid.
Everybody thinks
they're operating
on that left-hand
side, that what they're
doing and responding to you
is legitimate and strategic
in their view.
So what I like to say is
when you think about getting
their perspective, is to
think about their good reasons
for saying no to you, good
reasons on that left-hand side.
What were their good reasons
for saying no to you?
Because that's the hidden agenda
of any of these negotiations,
right?
It's their reasons
for saying no.
So let me tell you
the story actually
about the women I told you
about right in the beginning.
So she's a vice president,
chief financial officer
of a division of
an energy company.
And the condition of taking this
job was that she move to Texas.
And she moved to Texas, and
she was there for two years.
And her family said at
the end of two years,
we're going back
to Pennsylvania,
which is where they were
from, with or without you.
And that's what she said
to me, the negotiation
changed my life.
Because what she
recognized, first of all,
was that she had leverage.
And her leverage was that
the chief financial officer
of the company relied on her to
have a relationship with people
in the field.
So that made her feel like
she had value to negotiate.
The second thing
that she did, and I
think this is really
important-- when
you raise an issue in a little n
negotiation, chances are you're
raising a problem.
And when you raise a
problem, you're the problem.
And so it really makes sense
to come in with good options.
We call it in the book
anchor with options.
Because if you anchor
with options, you come in,
and it frames the negotiation.
So let me tell you
what this woman did.
Her name is Cheryl.
So Cheryl negotiated with
the chief financial officer.
And she came up with
this idea of something
she called the
tri-office, which was
some time in corporate
headquarters,
some time in the field, and
some time in Pennsylvania.
But then she thought
about, what are
his good reasons for saying no?
By the way, when we tell
people about negotiation,
we always say, prepare,
prepare, prepare.
And when you prepare,
prepare, prepare,
you often can't hear what
the good reasons are.
So it's really important to--
we call it being mindful.
So when she thought
about his good reasons,
first she thought he
might think she wouldn't
be able to do the
job, if she wasn't
in corporate headquarters,
she wouldn't really
be able to do the job.
So she built into her
offer performance criteria.
They would look at
performance criteria.
The second thing
is, she thought he
might think it was too costly.
He paid for a move
already, and he might not
want to do it again.
So she built in a
cost-sharing provision.
The third thing was, he
was afraid if she left,
he would lose his
connection to the field.
So they built in a way that
she could deal with the field.
He thought that she would
get tired of the commute.
So they had periodic check-ins.
And the final thing
was he wouldn't
want to change precedent.
There's nothing she
could do about that.
But what she did was think about
his good reasons for saying no.
And in the negotiations,
I always like to say,
if you know a good
reason that people
are going to say no, it's
great to start there.
So she was saying,
I think you're
worried about my
performance, that this
is going to jeopardize it.
He said, right.
And once they're able
to talk about it,
it sort of can lower the
resistance a little bit.
It's a nice story.
They did a pilot.
It worked.
And now she's vice president
and general manager
of that division.
So the final thing
I want to talk about
is what we call dealing
with resistance.
That is, you raise
something, so here it is.
You put out an idea.
The persons says,
"This will never work."
You say, "Yes, it will."
And he says, "You're wrong."
And she says, "No,
no, I'm right."
And what happens in
these kinds of things,
I talk about this as
moves and counter moves.
So when people don't want
to give you what you want,
they say things that can
put you on the defensive.
They're resistant,
and so they defend.
They question your competence.
They say, this budget
is way out of line.
Everybody else can do this.
Why can't you?
Or they criticize your style.
You're being unreasonable.
Or, don't get so upset.
They demean your ideas.
Where did you ever get
these numbers from?
This will never work.
Or they appeal for sympathy.
This is really the
killer, I think.
I really need your help on this.
I'm very stretched,
so please just hold.
It's what the boss
did in Isabel's case.
Or they flatter
you, another killer.
You're so good at this.
Why wouldn't you want to keep
doing it, all 80 hours of it?
And so what happens is, we get
into this move and counter move
like this, as
opposed to thinking
about what we call turns.
And turns change the dynamics.
So the first turn you can
always use is interruption.
Silence-- it's
very heavy, right?
You take a break.
You interrupt.
Because you never come back
to exactly the same place.
Or you can ask a question.
You can correct it, or
you can solve a problem.
So let me give you an example.
This is a story about a woman.
This is again from Africa.
She is a PhD economist,
works for a large NGO.
The coin of the realm is
doing research but also
having your work make a
difference on the ground.
So her name is
Rosalie, and she's
coming to talk-- you can
tell this organization--
to the assistant
director general.
You can get a sense of
what this organization must
be like with an assistant
director general.
And she comes and
she says, I've come
to talk to you about
funding to present
to the next
International Congress.
I just published an
important article
in "The Journal of
Agricultural Economics,"
and I want to present it.
And he says, I'm not
familiar with that journal,
but as you know, we need senior
people to come and present
at these conferences.
That's where we meet with
donors, and you're not ready.
And she says, I can't
believe you're saying that.
I am ready to present.
And he says, look, I really need
you to support the work here.
You're best at helping me
and the director general
get ready for the conference.
And she says, no
way am I just going
to help you present my data.
I need to be there, too.
And he says, don't get so upset.
And she says, I am not upset.
So that's an example of
resistance, counter resistance.
So let's look at it from
a perspective of turns.
So she says the same thing.
He says the same
thing, But instead
of responding in a counter
move, she asks a question.
Help me understand
the criteria you
use to determine whether
people are ready.
So she opens it up.
And so he says pretty
much the same thing,
but she hears it
differently, right?
She asks a question,
he gives a reason.
Then knowing that,
she can correct it.
I understand what a
priority this project is,
and I want to support you
and the director general
so you can meet with donors.
And he says, I'm
glad you understand.
OK, so now she's
getting cooled out here.
That doesn't work.
So she jumps to the problem.
And she says, since I am
most familiar with the data,
I think the best way to
support the project is
for me to do the presentations
and be available to answer
questions the donors have.
That would help the
donors have confidence
in our junior
researchers, right?
So she expands the
problem from just herself
to something that's good
for the organization.
It's good for junior
resources and for donors
to know that junior researchers
are doing important work.
And so he says, actually,
I think that will work.
I'm going to run it by the DG.
Now obviously, this is a very
stylized kind of situation.
But the idea about
being prepared
for when people are going to
use these moves that put you
on the defensive-- and what
we like to say in the book,
which I didn't talk
about today, is
knowing what you know about
the person you're dealing with,
what they do in these
kinds of negotiations,
so you can be prepared.
So the final thing I'll
just say is this book--
the subtitle of the book
is called, "Turning Small
Wins into Big Gains."
And our notion about
this is that these kinds
of negotiations
over these issues
actually make some change.
So if you think about Isabel
that was doing this extra work,
she becomes a role model
for changing the idea
that invisible work and
just helping has no cost.
It has a cost.
And it should be
built in to a job.
Cheryl in this tri-office
actually changes a precedent.
It is no longer the
case that it is expected
that people will move
to the corporate office
as a condition of taking on
a very senior leadership job.
They might, but
it's now negotiable.
It's not just assumed.
And Rosalie changes the role
of the junior researchers.
Now the leadership
of the organization
is open to the idea
that it's actually
a good thing for junior
researchers to present.
So negotiation becomes
a way to change
kind of cultural practices.
So I think it's not
just good for you.
I think it could be good
for the organization.
So we have some
time for questions.
People have questions?
CATHY CHEN: This
one is from Becca.
I'd love tips on helping
a manager understand
the value of work that is done
outside of one's core role,
for example, training
or mentoring others.
It's important for the greater
good, Google or [INAUDIBLE],
but can be hard to defend in the
face of an ambitious team goal.
DEBORAH KOLB: Right, so again,
I think the most important thing
there is how do you
connect why it's good?
What are the benefits?
You have to be able to quantify
those benefits in some way.
Sometimes people say,
when we mentor people,
it means that they stay.
In reading this
book about Google,
losing talent is something that
Google isn't so happy about.
So the idea if you're
mentoring people
to stay, especially if they're
in a minority group, the idea
that you're helping
them stay would
be putting this in a currency
that has value, presumably,
to the person
you're dealing with.
Other people have suggestions
for how you do that as well?
I don't think I have to be the
one answering that question.
How do you make invisible work
that you do that isn't just
generically valued because it
doesn't contribute directly
to the work you're doing, how
do you claim value for it?
Anybody have any other ideas?
Have you done it?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Can you talk about
[INAUDIBLE] reviews with
your manager, and--
DEBORAH KOLB: Build
it into your goals?
AUDIENCE: Just be very explicit,
talk about it in reviews,
make it an explicit goal,
and check in on [INAUDIBLE].
DEBORAH KOLB: Yeah, and
I think the idea there
is to connect what's
good-- I always like to say
there are a few principles
that I have here
that I had in my notes but I
didn't say it, and one of them
is connecting what's
good for you to what's
good for the organization.
And you need to be able to
talk about why it's good.
And the degree to which
you can do that I think
makes a difference.
AUDIENCE: I'm sorry.
Can you please either
repeat that or can you
repeat [INAUDIBLE] microphone
so that [INAUDIBLE] can also
hear that?
DEBORAH KOLB: So the
answer was in reviews,
bring it up and have it
built into your goals.
That's a good time,
and I say, negotiation
doesn't present itself as
sort of clear opportunities.
But reviews are often
a place to do that.
And in the book, we
have a lot of examples
about how you build in
these kinds of things
to ongoing conversations
like reviews,
like project reviews, how
you stop that conversation
and build something else in
that you want to accomplish.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So you
started by talking
about framing your
value in a way that
matters to the other party.
But in my experience as
a young professional,
when I was negotiating for my
first job prior to this one,
I had no idea what my value was.
I had grades, and
I had no idea how
to explain that grades
would be useful.
And I got a job, so somehow
they thought I had value.
But it was never clear
to me what they saw
or how I could highlight that.
DEBORAH KOLB: Right,
but when you're
getting hired right
out of school,
you don't have value on the
currency that has value yet.
They have to
determine what it is.
But over time in working,
you do have value
in a currency that has value.
I think the hiring is
sort of different, right?
I think Google looks for
talent and good grades, right?
So somebody thought
you had talent,
and you probably had good
grades, and they thought, OK.
I mean, what I gather
from reading about Google,
the interviewing process
is a really important part.
But I think over time--
that's not a little n
negotiation, actually.
That's more you're
negotiating to get hired.
It is a little n in
some ways, but it's not
in terms of the ongoing work.
So now you do have a value
and want to change things
or you want opportunities.
That's when you really, I
think, have to show your value.
AUDIENCE: So then I guess what
the persistent question is,
how do you know your
own value, especially as
a younger professional?
DEBORAH KOLB: Well, if
you don't know your value,
they won't know it, either.
And also talk to people.
So one of the things is we
always think we're on our own
in doing this.
Talk to other people
in your network.
Get some advice from people
who have done it before.
How do they see their value?
What are the kinds of
things that matter?
One of the things in the
book that we talk about
is knowing what you know about
the person you're dealing with.
How do they like to hear things?
What do they value?
So finding information
about the person
you're going to negotiate with
can also help you do that.
But you're not on
your own, exactly.
Do you have a
comment about that?
AUDIENCE: So I actually sit on
our New Grad Hiring Committee.
So I see this go by a lot.
I tend not to see
what the offers are,
but I do see the
candidates go by.
And as far as knowing what your
value is in that situation,
shop yourself around, right?
Often when I want to know
the value of an old piece
of electronics, I
go to eBay and see
what people are paying for it.
Shop yourself around.
See what Twitter will offer you.
See what Facebook
will offer you.
See what any other company
out there will offer you.
And then come back to
Google, because you
wanted to work at Google even
though you're interviewing
at all these other places.
But come back to them
say, well, these guys
are going to offer me this.
I have a competing offer.
Nothing gets the recruiters
into action faster than having
competing offers,
and I think you'll
find that true throughout
your professional career,
no matter what level you are
applying to be hired into.
DEBORAH KOLB: Getting
anothher offer is a BATNA.
The research suggests
you need to be
a little bit careful about
how you use that directly.
One of the things
that I like to say
is, when you have another
offer, you know your value.
And so therefore, what you're
asking for feels defensible.
You can stand behind it.
Some of the research
suggests, especially
with women, when you drag
out that other offer,
people don't hear it so well.
I think you're an experienced
person on the hiring committee.
Other people might
sort of not do it.
But it's--
AUDIENCE: I definitely
want to mention
I am not involved directly in
negotiating people's salaries.
I'm just involved [INAUDIBLE] --
DEBORAH KOLB: To sort of
looking, do they look good?
Right.
AUDIENCE: And I was
just going to say
in terms of knowing your
worth, talk to your peers,
talk to people in peer reviews.
DEBORAH KOLB: Exactly.
When
AUDIENCE: We have yearly perf,
think that's a great place.
And just get real-time
feedback, right?
You don't have to wait to
go-- just don't go and get
an offer, right?
I'm from HR.
But I think it's
more than just--
there are a lot of other ways
that just going out to see
what Facebook would pay you.
DEBORAH KOLB: Great.
Other questions?
CATHY CHEN: There's some
more questions on the Dory.
I think you can see them now.
DEBORAH KOLB: Yeah,
so in a collaborative,
scrappy work culture,
teams and individuals
are pulled in many directions.
Do you have tips for managing
a wide range of requests
and opportunities for
multiple unique sources?
Well again, it's a little bit
about knowing what you want.
You can't get what you want if
you don't know what you want.
And so if you're just
being buffeted by requests
and you can't anchor on
something that matters to,
I do think you need to
get advice about that.
Because if you
keep getting pulled
in all these
different directions,
that's what's going to happen.
And so you're not going to
be able to carve yourself
out a career and a program,
a program to progress.
So I think yes, you
need to have people that
can help you think about that.
That's why mentoring
is so important, right?
In a culture where
this happens a lot,
mentors are really key to
be able to talk to people
and get advice from them about
what makes sense here for me
and what doesn't
make sense for me.
So I think there is sort
of anchoring and knowing
what you want.
Because you can't get
it if you don't know it.
And I think it is
one of the things
that there's so
many opportunities,
it's hard to focus on it.
But I think if you don't,
it's very hard to push,
to negotiate for the thing.
Then you can't really negotiate
for the things you want, just
been pushed back and forth.
Now, you might want to narrow
it down to a few things
and use these things to
trade off of each other
so that it might help you
get exactly what you want.
I think there are a
lot of choices here.
And so I think
focusing is really key.
I think it this sounds
like a theme here.
There are sexy projects
and grunt work projects
on every team.
How do I negotiate
for the ones that
will set me up for
success, which are usually
the sexy ones?
So I guess I would say,
again, knowing what you want.
But doing a little of the
grunt-- we call this if-then,
right?
So I'm willing to do
this, if then I do that.
So you connect these
different parts
of what you're
being asked to do.
And that way, you really do
make it sort of a negotiation.
So there's a cost for
you doing the grunt work.
But if you're the
kind of person that
always says no to
that grunt work,
I think it's going
to be an issue.
But if you're the
kind of person that
always says yes
to the grunt work,
all you do is get grunt work.
So the issue is really
to make it a negotiation.
If-then, if I do this,
then I want to do that.
So always connect these tasks.
We talk in the book about how
to turn asks into negotiations.
Because that's really key.
You get asked all the
time, and how do you
make it into a negotiation?
So if-then, which
builds in reciprocity.
I'm willing to do this,
but then something else.
And I think that's important.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Can you
talk a little bit
about some of the basics, such
anchoring, which you talked
a little bit about,
whether it's you
starting the negotiations
at a certain point
then ratcheting back.
How big do you make
your initial ask?
DEBORAH KOLB:
Right, so anchoring
comes from negotiations when
you're tending to negotiate
about a single issue, right?
So you have an idea
of a bargaining zone,
and we make offers, and we move
back and forth on that zone.
It tends to be the
case, if you have
good information about the
other side's alternatives,
it pays you to make
the opening offer.
I don't think this is
little n negotiation advice.
This is external kind
of advice, because I
think there's consequences to
doing what I'm about to say.
It will end negotiations.
So let me be clear.
But when you have
good information
about the other
person's alternatives,
it behooves you to
make an opening offer.
That's what we call a
large opening offer.
Because you frame the
negotiations and you
anchor it in a way that's
advantageous to you.
If you don't have
good information
about the other
side's BATNA, you
run the risk of either
anchoring too low, in which case
you cut off a lot of
the bargaining zone,
or anchoring so
much off the charts
that people sort of walk away.
The way I like to use anchoring
in little n negotiation
is anchoring with solutions.
So you're asked to do
grunt work, for example.
Well, can you anchor
with a solution
about what you would do, some
of it, or who else would do it?
So anchoring becomes
solutions to problems.
Because you're always
trying to make trades.
I meant to tell my
trade story, so I guess
I'll tell my trade story now.
You're always looking
for making trades.
In all negotiations,
you never want
to negotiate about
a single issue.
You always want to negotiate
about more than one issue.
Because you want to do if-thens.
You want to have trades.
So here's my story about trades.
This is a story about
an anthropologist who's
studying the Navajo in Arizona.
She finished her field work, and
she's driving back to Phoenix.
And she passes a Navajo
woman on the road,
and she asks her if she wants
a ride back into Phoenix.
And this woman says, sure.
And this woman gets in the
car and is totally silent
for most of the ride.
Except for when they're
getting close to Phoenix,
the Navajo woman notices that
in between the two seats,
there's a bag.
And she asks the anthropologist
what's in the bag.
And the anthropologist
says, it's
a bottle of wine for my husband.
And the Navajo woman
says, good trade.
[LAUGHING]
So it's important to
think about trades, right?
Trades are important.
It's always sort of if-then.
I didn't really talk about
that that much in this talk,
but there's a lot of it in the
book, always about if-then.
And so anchoring in a single
offer kind of situation,
those are so rare.
It's not what you're doing.
Even when you're
negotiating salary,
that's not what you're doing.
There are so many other
pieces that are part of it.
So anchor with solutions.
Because I think it
does the same thing.
It frames the negotiation
in a situation
that's advantageous to you.
Because you've sort of thought
about how you frame it.
OK, so suppliers--
I'm not really
talking about that, suppliers,
how you negotiate with supplies
on a short timeline to pull
in dates due to urgent demand.
Again, I think it's an
if-then kind of thing.
Will they do it this time,
and in return, you'll
give them something else later.
And then the then
could be how we
keep each other informed so that
we know more what's happening.
Yeah, so somebody is
negotiating on behalf of you,
and they don't negotiate well.
How would you prepare
them to negotiate?
Well, I think that's a
really important issue.
When you are counting on
people to negotiate for you,
you want to have the first
negotiation with them.
What is it you want them to do?
And sometimes they actually
might need some help.
When they have to
negotiate on your behalf,
there may be a consequence
to negotiating on your behalf
that they don't want to pick up.
And so I think you have to
find ways to sort of help
them do that, help them
figure out exactly how they
would negotiate on your behalf.
You may not have
all the information
that they have about
options and policies.
You want to ask them
for that information.
So this negotiation
with your manager
is actually the
first negotiation.
It's not something that you're
just sort of talking to them.
It is negotiating to get them
to buy in to be your advocate.
And that's what you're
asking them to do.
Sales teams--
that's an open-ended
question that I don't actually
have a lot of advice for.
I would suggest you talk to
other people on your sales team
to get advice for that.
All right, that's it.
I interviewed some
people before I came here
to get some other information.
And so one of the
things I learned
was the key scarce
resource at Google is time.
So one of the major things
that you're negotiating about
is really time.
And so it's trying to
think about creative ways
to negotiate about time.
And so we have some ideas
in the book about that
as well, especially in terms
of negotiating about work
and personal life issues.
So are there any
other questions?
Well, thank you.
It's been a real pleasure.
I hope you like the
book and you use it.
And if you do have
questions, Cathy
has ways to get
in touch with me.
I'd be happy to sort
of answer them online.
I think there's sort
of a theme here about
the kind of questions.
You're overwhelmed with choices.
And you're having a
hard time negotiating
about those kinds of choices.
And I think it really starts
with you being clear about what
it is you want.
I guess the other thing
that I didn't say,
I said connect what's
good for you to what's
good for your organization
and convert an ask
into a negotiation.
The way you do that
is always, yes and.
That's what builds [INAUDIBLE].
Yes, I'm willing to do this,
and here's what I need.
So you're always thinking
about connecting it and making
it a negotiation.
People always say, I
need more help saying no.
I don't think that's right.
I think you want to have
help saying yes and.
And when you put the
and out, they may say,
well, I can't do that.
You say, well, then maybe
it's not going to work, right?
But at least you've had
a negotiation about it.
So I would encourage you
in this negotiation culture
to think about some
of these principles.
So thank you.
[APPLAUSE]